l'est de trinidad sous les eaux après
trois jours depuis consécutif des
conditions météorologiques inhabituelles
provoquant des inondations fluviales et
d'importants dégâts
de nombreuses routes sont coupées des
milliers de personnes sont désormais
isolée sur ces images des familles
entières tentent de fuir leurs maisons
car les eaux atteignent déjà les 1 mètre
en attendant l'arrivée des secours
quelques habitants patiente dans la
benne de leurs voitures pour d'autres la
circulation dans cette zone ne se fera
qu'en bateau pour ceux qui parviendront
à rejoindre l'ouest de l'île pour
bénéficier de soins
il faudra se diriger dans les abris
nationaux les hôpitaux étant saturés
le transport aérien est suspendu les
écoles seront fermées demain lundi car
selon les services météorologiques de
trinidad
les pluies devraient continuer jusqu'à
mardi 18h même si aucun décès n'a été
signalé
le niveau d'alerté rouge reste toujours
activée